Okay. Now that you've been through the material from Lesson
One, let's see if you can complete the concept map
that we showed earlier. Remember a concept map is just
connecting words to each other using other concepts or words that
are relevant to both. For example, a genome is a
genetic instructions for traits, and both are influenced by something that
belongs in this blank here. What I want you to
do is fill in each blank you see in the concept
map using words that you find in the word bank
over here. If you think you know the correct word for
that blank, just take it from the word bank and
type it into the box you see in the concept map.